dis moi c'est pareil tu n'envoies
invertir hoerdtois d'apporter mixte et
pousser plus loin du pasteurdon thierry
kto deuxième feu rouge à points qui rira
le dernier
deuxième place d'un plan qui rit tout en
à droite quelle heure il est certain que
j'allais en réserve ils sont partis
comme si j'allais à l'achat ce serait un
problème de journée il faudra même pas
une bonne solution
lorsqu'il fait beau vous allez retrouver
c'est pour le plaisir de regarder le jeu
n'ont absolument pas l'intérêt de
quality au football j'aime beaucoup
l'ambiance mais j'y vais lorsqu'il fait
beau seulement je vous dis avec mon
fiche il m
il aime courir dans dans l'herbe idem le
ballon aussi c'était ce qui promet et
j'ai bien tout ça j'y vais pour
l'ambiance ou si l'ambiance est très
bonne
si vous aviez le choix si votre marine
vous le laissez oui qu'est-ce que vous
êtes variés faire le dimanche
je crois qu'on peut faire des tas de
choses ensemble j'aimerais en et des
distractions
comment on va évidemment se voit toute
la semaine on pourrait se voir pour le
plaisir aussi
vous êtes un peu germes du football
jalouse plus maintenant vous avez été
j'ai été jaloux du tennis je me suis
fait une raison consignes bol pour ma
part plus il ya de gens qui font du
sport plus je suis content et je
considère que mon dieu la femme d'un
footballeur
pas terrible quoi surtout des
footballeur comme les nôtres il
s'entraîne une fois ou deux par semaine
et une joue le dimanche
si vous ne pensez pas qu'il est mieux
qu'il soit sur un stade que dans un
bistrot jeu rien contre les bistrots
enfin tout de même pièce ou c'est que
quelques heures d'une semaine sacrifier
pour pour quelquefois le le portel que
fois le matière d'un ménage
parfois il prend pas la caméra
lorsque vous regardez la télévision et
que vous regardez le sport parce que
c'est le sport que votre mari veut
regarder
quelquefois il attendra une petite
réflexion encore du sport toujours
d'histoire et c'est tout ça s'arrête là
non il regarde vous pouvez me dire
qu'est ce qui est gagné la coupe cette
année je m'intéresse aux au club c'est
tout vous accompagnez toujours votre
mari pratiquement toujours vous quel que
soit le temps oui vous regardez le match
où vous parlez avec des amis les deux
mais vous êtes capable si on vous
demande whisky des ensembles de dire au
score ni en le suivant ou parce que vous
jetez un oeil de temps en temps ah non
je me rends compte des buts même s'il
joue votre mari allait faire un match
elle jouait un match trop loin pour vous
puissiez la compagnie vous enverriez de
toute façon je l'accompagnerai la
journée nous sommes dimanche où était
votre femme
je pense que les peuples ont fort est en
train de se promener faire du rock elle
vient elle ne vient que très rarement
sur le terrain de football c'est vrai
ça ne vous ennuie pas un peu pourquoi sa
mort n'est pas que des temps pourquoi au
contraire au contraire offs je crois que
ça les amuse pas trop alors au mieux
qu'elle soit pas là j'ai plutôt de la
sympathie ou plutôt de l'antipathie pour
le football gfa l'antipathie nous mais
c'est un jeu qui ne m'intéresse pas
c'est un jeu qui m'intéresse pas face à
jeux de ballons que ma tasse pas je
préfère le rugby je préfère basket je
peux faire le volet mais le foot non
vous avez des discussions quel que soit
ce sujet là oui ça pose un problème
parce que mon mari bon travail de la
semaine je travaille aussi on se voit le
soir le soit encore fatigué on se remet
au travail c'est qu'avec paris donc le
week end on voudrait puisqu'on va la
campagne reste un pas ensemble je
voudrais et joue au foot je joue au foot
quand il a un match le dimanche après
midi mais des fois il a des tournois
donc par le matin à 8 heures l'entrée
reçoit vous ne pensez pas que c'est
aussi une façon pour votre mari de
s'exprimer de de faire une chose dont il
a envie
ça ne vous paraît pas suffisant en ce
qui vous concerne mais c'est difficile
mais quand même laisser les gens libres
commencé quand même une individus libres
il fait ce qu'il veut je vais pas
obliger l empêcher de faire votre ce
soir ce serait pas le foot ce sera autre
chose
enfin l'ambiance entre entre entre
footballeur enfin entre entre camarades
match est très très mal est ce qu'il
faut je pense c'est faux est-ce que ça
que je les empêche pas de foot parce que
il retrouve ses cette camaraderie et il
faut quand même pas l'étouffer il faut
partir est la journée avec bobonne et le
bébé et il faut quand même qu'ils
aillent voir des amis il et il trouve là
il trouve des jantes qui font du foot et
qui aiment ça comme lui n'est pas fou
mais vous comprenez votre mari oui bon
je n'aime pas faute
et l'horreur j'espère j'espère parce
qu'il passe son temps à je vous foot il
ya que ça qui pak qui compte et ensuite
la semaine ea la maladie lamal ici la
balle là il a reçu un coup
il faut il faut soigner il faut passer
il faut alors ça ça va bien ça va oui
enfile les perles
ah bon c'est bien elle qui voit la rb6 a
gagné l'on vendait il dimanche j'ai mal
aux pieds
alors là je suis pas bien fait mais
qu'est ce qu'il fallait massage encore
cette semaine je pars dans se plaindre
parce que c'est bien